so there's a new trailer for Ghost
Busters and I gotta be honest guys I
really debated whether or not I was
going to even put a video Don it
literally I flipped a coin to try and
figure out whether I should bother doing
this because I couldn't decide I very
little about this thing worked for me
but there isn't all that much that I can
think to say about it that I didn't
already say want to get my video on the
first trailer that came out here's what
I'm not gonna do I'm not gonna reiterate
all this or at least I'm gonna try to
not reiterate all the same points that I
said last time I will for one last time
point I hate the fact that this is a
reboot and discounts the old continuity
I will always hate that the jokes for
the most part still didn't land there
were a couple that I chuckle that I will
cop to chuckling at the selfie joke it
was dumb but I laughed I'm not gonna lie
but most of the other jokes were either
ones we'd already seen before and Joe
he's almost never funny same time you
see it anyway or they just didn't land
I'm about split 50-50 on what I think
about the actual ghost most of the stuff
that they showed sort of in the first
half of the trailer the more sort of
actually trying to be spooky works
pretty well as far as I'm concerned add
the look of it you know all the blue
ghost sort of slowly turning that one in
the library before starts vomiting up
slime I think that's still a really cool
design I like the sort of ethereal but
you can see a skeleton but it looks you
know like a person it's a cool look I
like that there's a thing with like all
these ghosts in mirrors and they're kind
of pressing up against that was a cool
look the other thing that I kind of like
and I actually even have a reason to
think might even be good in the movie is
actually the action scenes we only get
little snippets of it but I like the
intensity of the actresses I like sort
of the rhythm that we get from the
little snippets of action that we see it
looks kind of inventive it looks fun it
looks intense so I'm looking forward to
that aspect of course given that thing
is selling itself as hard as it is at to
be a comedy and the few things I mean I
think
might actually be good have nothing to
do with the comedic elements that's a
problem and actually in a way that kind
of to me speaks to they I think they
really came at this thing from
completely the wrong angle and I mean
even aside from the reboot factor it
feels like they came at this trying to
make a comedy now it's always struck me
a slightly odd that the original
Ghostbusters gets classified as a comedy
it is extremely funny it's hilarious but
the thing is it's not there to be funny
being funny is not the point it's
telling a really interesting compelling
story it it is allowed to get intense
and really dig into things and be spooky
and creepy and honestly that first
Ghostbusters movie as great as the jokes
are you can strip every single joke out
of that movie and it would still be
really compelling and really fascinating
there's almost no seen in the original
Ghostbusters that exists for the sake of
telling a joke there are scenes that are
moving the story forward or showing us
more about the ghosts or how the
technology works you know information
that we need and they find a way to
integrate jokes into that but the joke
service the story the vibe that I get
from this is very much what is been
going on lately in comedy films which is
that they come up with the jokes and
then justify a scene to allow them to
tell those jokes which is a way of doing
company that I don't like in the first
place and I think was a really bad way
to just come at doing Ghostbusters
because when you prioritize the jokes
over the story when it is such a
compelling and interesting story you're
just setting yourself up to annoy
everybody because now if the jokes don't
land you've got nothing left original
Ghostbusters you can watch that not even
get the jokes and I think that
particularly funny but there's still
stuff there you can latch on to some of
the other cell in the trail I can't
decide what I feel about the fact that
they're going for these I mean like that
there's a dragon ghost I can't decide
what I think about that there's part of
me that wants to say it's kind of stupid
but it's very reminiscent of the
Ghostbusters cartoon which is something
that i love but I mean that was a
cartoon it was for little little kids so
I don't I don't know it doesn't excite
me I'll say that much and I'm kind of
really annoyed that they showed us a
Kevin Chris Hemsworth getting possessed
and then showing a snippet that makes it
look pretty clear
like he is going to factor into the
climax like and somehow they're going to
have to take him down at the end and
whatever's possessing him is like part
of the really big thing it's not just
he's possessed oh we fix it we move on
which unfortunately makes it feel like
something that I'd complain about lately
with trailers they're giving away a big
chunk of the climax i think watching the
movie if this was a character that I
liked I don't know if I was gonna like
him or not but if it was and he then got
possessed and he's zooming off to help
the ghost and we're going to the climax
that could have really upped the tension
for the climax and the tension is about
the only thing I've got any hope for
left cuz as i said the action scenes
look okay but now i already know that's
going to happen i'm not as angry about
it because this isn't a movie i care as
much about both i would put this right
up there as being of the exact same
level of problem as spoiling the
wolverine reveal in the latest Xmen
apocalypse trailer or spoiling the
doomsday reveal in batman be superman
why our trailers doing this so part of
me wants to save the trailer slightly
better because like i said i'm able to
kind of hone in on the action element
and go maybe that'll work but i don't
know if i'm doing that just because I've
kind of already resigned myself to the
fact that I'm probably not gonna like
this movie and I'm just trying to grasp
it anything that might give me any level
of enjoyment I don't I don't know if I
can give the trailer props for that just
because my mindset is in such a place or
I'm like something anything where is it
but I don't really have the energy to be
angry about this thing anymore which I'm
actually kind of glad at because i am
gonna see this thing because i want to
give it the chance to win me over I
actually would much prefer to enjoy it
but I'm not expecting to and I think
it's better for just me and my soul to
not go in angry going in resigned is
probably not the best thing either but i
think it's the better option if those
are the only things that I've got going
for me so second Ghostbusters trailer
have you seen it what you think about it
whatever you thought drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter I Council of geeks please
feel free to check out the council geeks
podcast available on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned